BOTH TEAMS WANT TO BE PHYSICAL
LOWRY TAKES A SWIPE ATOMRIE
WITH A GOOD STOP OFF TA EHLERS L
BACK FOR NATHAN BEAULIEU.
RIPS ITCKLED UP
INTO THE EYES OF BRADEN HOLTBY
AVMENTD SHOT THAT LOOKS  GAME.
>> Dennis: DENIS GURIANOV NOT
IN THE LINEUP FORBENN IN HIS
NINTH GAME OF THE SEASON.
YOU CAN SEE THE WAY HE IN WAY.
FOUR-FOR-FOUR.
JETS WITH THE MAN-ADVANTAGE HERE
TO START THE SECONDN.
BLAKE WHEELER UP TOP TO SCHMIDT
AND DENNIS DOWN AT TONINATO.
KYLE CONNOR.
ODD-MAN RUSH.
CLEARED.
ADAM LOWRY TRYING TO SQUEEZE IT
WIDE BY ESAT GOT THAT TOE DRAG
TO GO AND ROBERTSON JUST
THEY'VE BEEN OPPORTUNISTIC HERE
TONIGHT, THEY. DEFENDERS NOT
TO CHEAT.
>> Dennis: PIERRE-LUC
A REALLY NIC SVECHNIKOV.
KYLE CONNOR.FF THE STICKCK
THIS GETS SENT IN, NEARSIDE
ROBERTSON.
DOWN TO THE GOALLINE IT PAVELSKN
EVERYBODY PILES ON OVER TOP OF
COMRIE.
OVER TOP OF THE BLUE PAININ A S.
WATCHED BY HARK K JANVIER, UP DP
DOWN, ONE TOO M M
GET EXTRA
SCHEIFELE WINS THE FA SHOT EHLE.
SCHEIFELE.